let's start with the word because it
always starts with the word tell us
about the the journey of the script and
how we went up at this moment so yeah I
wrote the script 25 years ago is my
first assignment and at Disney with
trilogy entertainment and I told them I
wanted to write an action-adventure
character because the previous attempts
at you know doing these black stories
historical stories were all history
lessons and I wanted to do something
exciting and vivid and would sell is
entertainment and you know because I was
working for the Writers Guild minimum
they didn't much care and you know I
turned it in and they sent me a bottle
of champagne and I said why and they
said cuz the scripts great and I said
aren't all of them great I really didn't
know anything about the business and
then Disney said we're not gonna make it
and I once again didn't understand why
aren't you gonna make it you just paid
for it and they said you know we have
hundreds of scripts we paid for so I
asked John Watson the principal I said
are you gonna make them you know let's
go out to the town he said we can't do
that we're exclusive
he said you take the script now you're
the producer get it made now I didn't
realize the time he's sending me on a
fool's errand so that's kind of the
start of it and over the 20-year period
yeah I took it to everybody but the town
wasn't ready to they weren't ready to do
that and I realized the environment had
to change so when I kept looking for a
comp after all that rejections and Debra
says the comp is uh hidden figures and
I'm sure that helped but I was looking
for something very specific and my agent
called me about I think seven or eight
years ago but he said 12 years of slave
is in development and I said that's the
comp I need he said well let's see if it
comes if it gets made and does it do
business and it did both of those things
it took so two years after it came out
that's when I called Deborah 2015 and I
said I got this
Harriet Tubman script and you know it's
different because it's action-adventure
and I'm sure she doesn't mind me say it
at the time
she took maybe about a week for it she
said this is great I said well you act
surprised and you said well I thought it
was gonna be a history that's right and
exactly I've embraced it and said she is
like bad as Pam Grier and I totally you
know you you positioned her as this
historical action heroine and we have
carried that forward you know to what
you just saw tonight so when I came on
it was really about trying to make it
trying to really fill in the details of
her life through the research like
trying to get the real the the real
Harriet Tubman story in the authentic
story of her family and you know just to
bring the real woman but to keep that
sense of you know the action heroine
Cynthia this which you've done so
remarkable how was it stepping how was
it staring into these shoes these
historical shoes from 150 plus uij wait
till I say 170 plus years I can't do my
math very well to a time that was so
vastly different from ours yet there's
still a few little remnants around today
and it was overwhelming because I knew
there was a big job ahead and I knew I
take the responsibility very seriously
of telling the story and trying trying
to be as truthful honest and is full as
I possibly could so I did the research
made sure I did my research I knew it
was gonna be a terribly physical job so
I got myself ready training most days
every day and then whilst I was on it I
was training again and sitting with
Casey was really a blessing um the two
of us were able to have a lot of
conversation about what we wanted to
bring out her looking at pictures trying
to map her face trying to find her voice
because there's no recording of her so
we had to find something that was very
different to mine both in speaking and
singing because singing really was a
part of her her story and breaking those
things down and using the
to really find her made the task less
gargantuan I guess yeah I mean you say
thing was a part of her story could you
give us a bit more detail on that well
um so for me singing it is a wonderful
way of telling stories and communicating
stories but for Harriet it really was
about pure communication it was about
getting something from me to you so she
would use specific verses in the songs
that we heard to tell people that she
was there that she was leaving but I was
safe that it wasn't safe when to leave
when not to leave come now don't come
now all of those things and so we wanted
to make sure that what we had was not
flowery or colored in any way it was
pure and specific and that's what we
were trying to find when it comes to
Elvis fascinating to see that it would
work that sort of subtle communication I
think it's it's super important to the
story and it's super important to
understanding the movement of resistance
in in in stories about enslaved people I
mean that this was a very sophisticated
form of communication it wasn't merely
comfort or it wasn't merely taken you
know um the overseers thought that the
slaves were happy when they were singing
but in fact there was a very
sophisticated communication going on and
so we really wanted to UM talk about
that because it was such so much a part
of Harriet's story and Joe for you what
were they what were the challenges of
inhabiting such a conflicted character
somebody who's embodying really all of
the twisted contradictions of slavery in
the sense they're he's a he's a boss
he's a complicated bastard it's tricky I
was saying before because there's really
nothing to relate to in terms of his
position and his family and what they
did and you know the idea of slavery is
completely is so far removed in this
abhorrent and repulsive and so it's
tricky to find a way and from there but
what I tried to do was find some kind of
human element with him and that made him
more accessible and I think for Gideon
it was that deep sense of confusion
about his feelings for men see of
Harriet Simba for you they would have
grown up as children and played together
and they would have been an ensign
and a purity between them and then a
certain age he would have been told that
that's no longer acceptable and the line
would have been drawn and it would been
told that there's a division now or
there's hate even now and the amount of
confusion that must have left him with
is unimaginable and I think he's someone
who's deeply tangled inside and whatever
whatever that is this deep down in him
whether it's love or whatever that is
there wasn't a language within him or
around him and to allow that what to
understand that or express that and so I
tried to understand him more from that
more human side of confusion or family
loyalty and obligation because trying to
understand it from the point of view of
just black and white slavery it's it's
it's you know I'm it's impossible I want
to talk a little bit more about how this
whole caste came together mm-hmm
how was that process so I went to go see
the color purple and just you know just
cuz it was amazing
and just sat there and was blown away by
this one and said she's our Harriet and
met her we met like a week later at the
Mandarin Oriental in the sky lounge and
you know you guys know Sealy is is
humble and plain and and this woman
walked in you know looking fabulous and
I just I was like she's Harriet I mean
it just because casting is everything
and casting a biopic is everything and
you just embodied her the essence of
strength and fierceness you're you're
petite but you were ten feet tall and as
everybody met her Gregg went to go see
the play and everybody like oh yeah done
we're done we're done so I'd like to ask
you Terrence about the score because the
score for me is it's so orchestral moody
its contemporary yet it evokes the
period it has this crazy duality and
it's so American I want to talk to you I
would love to hear about your strategy
for this and how
all came about well some of the things
that you're talking about is was
purposely done I kind of felt like
Harriet's story needed to have grandeur
you know it needed to have something
that could place it in another realm you
know I know sometimes but but movies
like this people want to go the
historically accurate route I didn't
necessarily want to do that I wanted
this story to be something that could
resonate around the world
you know but at the same time Harrah's
character men is complex it's it's it's
an interesting thing because you know
was we were talking about it earlier
when Casey first called me and talked to
me about it being a superhero film I had
this whole notion of what that would
sound like you know and I started put
but even before she started shooting and
I started doing little things in my
studio and coming up a little rhythmic
ideas and none of that stuff work you
know because I realized I was coming
from it from the framework of thinking
like a man you know and when I started
to see the the film and just her
performance was just amazing and very
inspiring for me when I saw it I said oh
this that I have to take a totally
different approach because hair it was a
very strong person but also very
compassionate and we all have been
talking about has her conviction of her
faith so all of those three things had
to play a role in what eventually became
the score I started coming up with ideas
and then Casey came down to New Orleans
and she came out for Jazz Fest as one
does yeah yeah yeah I mean so we did a
2-foot which we hung out for Jazz Fest
and then while a family was out in
vibing we shall say we went up to the
studio and just had a long conversation
and I played uh some things and just we
just went through it scene by scene and
just kind of whittled away and she would
tell me no this is too big here
I think it should be this here and we
just kind of arrived there what we have
now what was it like for you guys you
know dressed that way working this
weather functioning in that environment
and corsets yeah it was definitely a
challenge for me because I was always a
lot of the physicals as well the stunts
so I was doing on my own I did my stance
bar one so it meant that I was handling
corsets and petticoats and other things
with really cold weather and mud and
rain and and and but I felt like that
was all really necessary I felt like
that was the best way for me to get as
close to her experience as I possibly
could I was really trying to remove any
I guess you can call it a veil any veils
between myself and her so I could be as
truthful as I possibly could I always
knew that I would be safe
I knew that however cold it would get or
however difficult it might be I would
always be able to come out on the other
side and beat and be safe but I don't
know that Harriet knew that you know so
I think as I was willing to do and go as
far as they possibly could
knowing that she didn't have a choice to
do so or not well thank you guys we're
out of time